Tony Dungy joining us cotton old attire
coaches corner more of your phone calls
coming up Kurt Warner who was the
starting quarterback with the Giants and
then Eli took over and 210 starts in now
he turns it over to Geno Smith would you
make of the news of Eli Manning being
benched coach well my first reaction
then was why you mentioned Eli's taking
over in the middle of the season for
Kurt Warner that one made some sense
Eli is going to be your quarterback of
the future they thought that was the
time to do it Kurt Warner was a great
player but you had Eli Manning in the
wings why are you making this switch now
are you going to is there going to help
you win game right now no that that's
not going to happen
yes Geno Smith you want to see if he's
the quarterback in the future I think
everyone in New York knows that's not
the case is Davis with the quarterback
of the future I think we saw what
happened with Nathan Peterman going in a
rookie quarterback with no practice four
weeks to go in against an NFL defense
with a team that's struggling even if he
is if he is the next coming of Tom Brady
he's not going to play well in this
situation I just don't understand what
they're doing who do you think made this
call I'm not really sure it to me if I
can't see the organization making this
call if they did it was the wrong way to
do it and and so I'd have to say this
has been McAdoo
yeah that's what's surprising that I
don't understand the move if you're
bringing in Geno Smith when Ben McAdoo
says we're trying to win games we want
to evaluate the other quarterbacks on
the roster Davis Webb is the one that I
don't know about I know about Geno Smith
I don't know about Davis Webb if you put
Davis Webb as the starting quarterback
do you think people have less of a
reaction to this than Geno Smith in
there yes that would make more sense to
me I still think it would be foolish but
it would make at least would make sense
for an organization to take out a
two-time Super Bowl winner your
quarterback who's been your franchise
quarterback for all these years to put
Geno Smith in make no sense to me
and I do think they'd be doing Webb a
disservice by putting him in in this
situation when they're running again
struggling their offensive line
struggling and now we're going to see
how you how you do know and and why stop
Eli's strength why you know take five
games from this man's career that you're
not really going to accomplish anything
it to me it doesn't make sense at all do
you think Eli's with the Giants next
year you know I hope so but but I don't
know was this going on I really don't
know to me that you're almost saying
we're going to evaluating these
quarterbacks for the future you're
almost saying no I don't want a lie here
next year the 49ers are going to start
Jimmy Garoppolo why did it take this
long coach I'm not really sure again
that one to be I mean I did like CJ's
brothers and what they saw him in
training camp but today you trade for
Garoppolo you're not going to the
playoffs this year put him in now we
really do want to see what this guy can
do on a short schedule in doing them he
look great let's see what he can do here
we gave up a second rounder form
put him in I don't understand that
that's almost like deshaun Watson and
you draft him and move up to get him and
you don't put him in I don't under and I
love John this but I do not understand
why Garoppolo was not playing sooner
because I don't know about Jimmy
Garoppolo I know that he looks like he
has the pedigree he was Brady's backup
he played well in the you know a couple
games that he played but then he got
hurt if I'm going to invest a hundred
million dollars or I'm gonna franchise
him at twenty five million dollars I
still need to know of Jimmy Garoppolo
and I see him on a day-to-day basis
preparing for a game following up after
a game after a loss and you get ready
for the next game those are the kind of
things I want to see what kind of leader
is he and that's why I didn't understand
this I can only protect him for so long
I got to put him in there at some point
do you remember the name Matt Flynn yes
had a couple of huge games in Green Bay
hey this guy's would be great
Seattle pays a ton of money to go get
him and you know I'm not saying at all
that Garoppolo is going to be Matt slim
but he plays a couple of game jacobi
percent
played some great games and newing you
know so you can't say off two or three
games this guy is definitely going to be
the next Tom Brady so you're right you
have to find out and they to me the
49ers had the perfect chance to find out
this year when it wasn't gonna hurt him
too much good to visit with you tone
I'll see you on Sunday night that's Tony
Dungy NBC football night in America
analyst Hall of Famer Continental Tire
coaches corner appearance by Tony from
Sunday rain to snow and everything in
between Continental tires engineered to
tire for what you do extraordinary
performance and reliability putting
confidence into driving for more info in
the location of a dealer near you visit
Continental Tire Calm Continental Tire
for what you do for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]